la première ministre elisabeth borne a
été filmé en train de voter à
l'assemblée le 19 juillet alors que
c'est interdit pour rappel il est
interdit de fumer dans les lieux de
travail fermés et couverts à usage
collectif comme l'assemblée nationale
selon le ministère du travail toute
personne fumant dans un lieu à usage
collectif soumis à l'interdiction de
fumer or de l'emplacement spécifique
réservé aux fumeurs est passible d'une
contravention de la troisième classe qui
lui fait encourir une amende forfaitaire
de 68 euros d'autres lieux interdisent
de vapoter comme les établissements
scolaires ou les moyens de transports
collectifs fermés dans certains de ces
lieux-là monde peut aller jusqu'à 150
euros ce n'est pas la première fois qu
elisabeth bornes va potes à l'assemblée
en novembre 2020 1er janvier 2021 alors
qu'elle était ministre du travail elle
avait déjà été aperçu en train de
papoter de l'assemblée